Stephen you lucky is a documentary
filmmaker a former HBO studio executive
a feature producer and most recently
Dean of the school of film and
television at Loyola Marymount
University for eight years
last year he stepped down from LMU and
weeks later was accepted into the
Academy and joined the nickel
fellowships committee he is currently
working on a documentary on progressive
evangelicals presenting the award to
Sean Malcolm is Stephen you lucky
[Laughter]
I'd like to say that when I first
started out when I fell in love with
film I made documentaries and then when
I started doing feature as a fiction
work I still always found that films
that had a documentary basis or that
could have been could have been
documentaries were the ones that most
most interested me I look for example
the Battle of Algiers a film that could
take the reality of documentary yes
the reality the documentary doesn't yet
at the same time what you can't get in a
documentary a fictional film can supply
when I read mother I was absolutely
overwhelmed by the fact that I thought I
was seeing something that could become
as good a film as the Battle of Algiers
it is absolutely timeless work you've
got a sense of some of the drama in that
terrific scene that you just you just
saw and I just wanted to I'm very very
proud to be able to present the writer
of that script Sean Malcolm the nickel
fellowship award because I hope and
really pray and think that there's a
good chance that that film that script
could be made into a film because it
actually is the timing is perfect
absolutely perfect and for whoever is
interested in the film I know some
people are interested in it already I
would just urge that that hope that that
happened and on that note I'd like to
have asked Sean Malcom to step up
[Applause]
Wow Steve and I had no idea that you
were gonna equate me with something like
that and your words are so kind thank
you so much it's very hard to see all of
you out there but I know you're there I
have a few words I'll try to do it
quickly because I know we're on a time
limit but the truth is I do have a few
things to say so thank you for that
introduction thank you these actors that
was absolutely incredible you guys are
amazing for sharing your talent and time
tonight and breathing words breathing my
words our words into life for the very
first time when you write something you
don't have the benefit of anything other
than hear it in your head and you guys
are absolutely stunning thank you Geeta
for directing these scenes it's
incredible obviously I have to thank the
entire Nicol team Joan and Randy and
Chris and Melissa wherever you guys are
out there you're absolutely amazing this
week has been phenomenal and of course
all the readers and the Academy judges
who give their time every year and their
energy to this incredible fellowship we
could not do this without you and you
guys are so generous also I just want to
say a shout out to the nickel alumni who
spent their time with us this week they
shared their wisdom with us and that was
incredibly incredibly helpful of course
lastly but not least in terms of my
initial thanks we have to thank Donaghey
Nichol for the creation of this
fellowship this fellowship has been such
an inspiration to me and so many writers
around the world for so many years it's
an incredible gift and obviously an
incredible legacy so thank you to them
also I just want to quickly say thank
you to the Academy because I've always
really really wanted to say that
wherever the Academy is and thank you
specifically to the committee all the
members of the committee you guys this
this honor that you've bestowed on me
and the other four fellows this year is
it's really beyond comprehension I'm
absolutely humbled and also the other
finalists that were in our group it's an
incredible group of writers and I'm
absolutely stunned by all the talent and
just privileged to be part of this words
are never really gonna fully capture
what this means to me
but I am a writer so I figured I would
try imagine you've been slaving away at
this maddening pursuit called
screenwriting for 20 plus years and
you've really gotten comfortable with
the idea of obscurity it's fine really
total obscurity it's very comfortable
I'm good with it and then suddenly one
day you find yourself in the Academy's
headquarters on the seventh floor of
this very building you've just had lunch
with Eva Marie Saint in a room full of
legends and icons your phone is buzzing
because the producer is trying to get a
hold of you somebody who wants to make
your script you step out into the lounge
to return the phone call you're looking
at the panoramic view of the Hollywood
Hills and you find yourself staring
right at the Hollywood sign it's
literally it's ridiculous right it's
it's it's so on the nose nobody would
ever buy it the only thing that came
into my mind was a talking head song
once in a lifetime and you may say to
yourself well
how did I get here literally and then it
was oh my god what have I done that's
the magic of the nickel that's what this
is so how did I get here very quickly we
all take a different path
Aaron's path so straight and narrow mine
so circuitous if that's the way you
pronounce it circuitous thank you
so the truth is my journey began
twenty-one years ago in 1998 and in 1998
I actually submitted my very first
screenplay and ironically as evidence I
have my very first letter right here and
actually I was looking at this today I
mailed this script to 8949 Wilshire
Boulevard which is the building we are
standing in for I'm standing in you're
sitting on 21 years ago and yes for the
kids out there we did mail them in there
was not a thing called PDF so if you can
imagine thousands of physical scripts
coming to this building and how they did
it is just unbelievable shortly after
that letter was sent in I got my first
deer Shawn unfortunately your screenplay
did not advance to the quarterfinals and
so began a very long and twisted romance
from 98 to 2019 year after year I kept
writing submitting I tried dramas I
wrote a black comedy I wrote some
science fiction I did a ghost story I
did a techno thriller what do these guys
want from me
I even wrote a screenplay about a
screenwriter who writes a screenplay
about a screenwriter and one of them
dies along the way I forget which one it
was
it wasn't being John Malkovich trust me
mostly it went like this dear Shawn each
year the competition gets harder we
regret to inform you that your script la
blah blah blah Dublin but here's the
thing every single time I felt like
giving up a little piece of positive
reinforcement validation would come my
way from the nickel congratulations you
made the quarter with this script
congratulations
this one has advanced they would pull me
back in and then came mother and this
story unlike so many others it started
with a single photograph it was a
picture of a young boy in Aleppo about
the same age as my son who's here
tonight
he had just survived an airstrike just
minutes before and I knew I had to
somehow tell a story I didn't know who
he was and I probably never will but for
the first time in my life I tried
writing from my heart instead of my head
and that made a huge difference it's a
lesson as a writer that I will never
forget I know this is a celebration
tonight but it would not be right for me
to stand here and not say a word about
the Syrian people it's simply this we do
not have to accept what is happening to
our fellow human beings on this planet
we do not
every one of us can make a difference
together especially when we act together
if you want to help but you're unsure
how a great place to start is to simply
go to white helmet org or rescue org
they are doing work on the ground and
you with a few bucks can make a
difference let me just wrap up quickly
by thanking the people who've made a
difference in my life my mom Patty is
here tonight mom I love you I have no
doubt that my loyalty and love and
respect for all the women in my life
began with you I want to thank all my
friends and family that are here tonight
and around the world there's too many of
you that's a tree with many branches but
your love and support has meant
everything to me and I appreciate it so
much I especially want to thank my
beautiful wife Ivana she's here tonight
as well everyone knows I won the lottery
when I met you among so many other
things that I love about you your
instincts are flawless and so even
though we have a different taste in film
I know that if I write something I like
and you actually like it too I might
have actually done something different
very decent my two kids are here tonight
Julianna and Aiden guys are my pride and
joy I love you with all my heart and
being your dad is the best gift I ever
have and lastly I just have to thank my
dad Robert furo he was many things in
his life he was also an English
professor and an absolute connoisseur of
the written word and for a self-taught
writer like myself who never made it to
college having him as a dad turned out
to be a bit of incredible good fortune
even though we were so far apart
thousands of miles apart for many years
he read all my scripts he gave me his
feedback and he never once said a harsh
word or said anything about my stories
he only ever encouraged me
mother turned out to be the last script
that he would ever read he told me he
loved it and he was convinced that
something good was bound to come of it
and tonight proves he was right as he
usually was and so I just want to accept
this fellowship in his spirit because I
know it's his love of language that is
embedded in my DNA it is his love of
story that runs in my blood and it is
his kindness as both a father and a
teacher if that is forever written in my
heart thank you